this is the Emmy 70th year covering
television excellence so it's a big deal
and you know et8 been around for a lot
of these shows okay not all of them but
we have been covering the Emmys since
the mid 80s and it's been quite an
evolution the significance of the Emmy
it's the epitome ne the crowning glory
I'm pressing her a lot here to see I
hope it's not the last magnum p.i she's
just a living doll I never really
thought I'd be here under these
circumstances what queasy et has
celebrated alongside TVs biggest stars
who watch them skyrocket to fame like in
1983 when a 22-year old comic named
Eddie Murphy was about to take a gamble
on film this is my last year on
television period unless of course my
motion picture career falls apart then
it'll be like the other members open-toe
1986 Michael J Fox won his first of five
statuettes this is the best date I'm
sorry mom I'm taking her no Mike but you
can't relive the 80s without talking
about the fashion come on listen I don't
need to be sexy how do you describe it
um I guess sort of sophisticated
and just fun now Jason did you come
along to keep the guys away from Justine
in this dress tonight keep it relaxed is
this your first Emmy it's my first Emmys
first black tie event my first
everything the Olsen twins in the cast
of nine oh two one oh helped usher in
the 90s 1996 Seinfeld Julia
louis-dreyfus would take home her first
of 11 career Emmys I'm shocked I don't
know what to tell you I don't know how
come this happened in 1997 et was
backstage with an emotional Ellen her
first Emmy win came five months after
the historic coming-out episode it's it
it means a whole lot to me to be an
openly gay person that I thought would
be thrown out of the business I think
this is the most nerve-wracking part of
it I mean the rest of it isn't me honest
six friends from New York got their
first Emmy nod in 1995 but ultimately
lost to Frasier winning one of them too
much I think
in 1999 Jennifer and Brad made their red
carpet debut as a couple the next year
he rocked this Jen accessory in 2002
only eat Tevas backstage with the entire
friends crew the show won their first
Comedy Series Emmy Jen also took home a
statuette for the lead actress what are
you gonna do to celebrate we're going to
New Zealand
[Music]